I loved going back to huncles because I
did
it looks very familiar to anyone who saw
the Potter movies but obviously the
teaching staff are different
those names the stories the histories
that sit in the back of our mind from
the Potter series begin to weave their
way into peace I have some questions for
you
Dumbledore actually be shooting here at
Leacock where three of the films are
shot it's quite amazing me when I walked
on and saw all the trunks and Hogwarts
stickers and things like that
it's be amazing it's like the ultimate
childhood fantasy into play witches and
wizards but it was slightly order
out-of-body experience because I've
watched with everyone else those classes
it's only to be in it you're in there
doing it but then you look back on as
yourself and realize how special it was
go ahead and use
[Music]
ridiculous
I felt quite sentimental going back to
home
[Music]
I'm scared Professor Dumbledore everyone
is scared of something we did this yes
you're next
that's an unusual one what mr. Scamander
fears above everything else is having to
work in an office sir go ahead
ridiculous
[Music]
magic rooms
[Music]
only in rare Souls still we must skulk
in the shadows
[Music]
but the old ways serve us no longer
take it we've heard the rumors of all
television
that he will rise to dominance over the
Wizarding World
you're asking me to help hunt him down
I can't move against Grindelwald it has
to be you in your shoes I'd probably
refuse to as late
he leaned it come on
[Music]
you underestimate your talents misters
come on
their arrogance is a key to our victory
muggles are not lesser
not disposable
what you couldn't eat you never met a
monster you couldn't love three days
mr. Scamander do you think tumble to
will known for her
[Music]
are you ghost no I'm alive but I'm an
alchemist and therefore immortal oh you
gotta fly man J koalas oh oh you don't
look a day over 375
[Music]